C'est une grosse boite, voilà à quoi ça ressemble.
C'était entre moi et les baleines
et parfois, cela semble être une barrière entre vous et la réalité.
Y a-t-il une différence quand c'est votre téléphone ?
L'année dernière, je suis allée à Uluru, en Australie,
qui est cet énorme rocher qui domine le désert.
C'est la terre sacrée des Anangus,
les peuples aborigènes de cette région
et les propriétaires traditionnels de la terre.
Il y a des endroits spécifiques à Uluru
que vous ne pouvez pas photographier professionnellement
car ce sont des lieux sensibles d'un point de vue culturel,
équivalents aux écritures sacrées pour les Anangus.
De ce fait, la majorité de mes photos sont soit de loin, comme celle-ci,
ou prises d'angles spécifiques dans le parc.
Vous pourriez dire que certaines des vues les plus intéressantes et belles à Uluru
se trouvent dans ces zones sensibles,
mais la prière de ne pas les photographier est une invitation explicite et directe
à en apprendre plus sur la terre, son importance et son peuple.
N'est-ce pas ce que nous devrions faire ?
Il n'a vite plus été question de moi durant ma visite à Uluru,
mais d'établir un lien avec l'endroit.
Avec ironie et sans surprise,
j'ai découvert que la présence et l'attachement
s'avèrent résulter en des images plus captivantes.
Nous pouvons probablement dire des réseaux sociaux
que c'est un bon endroit pour partager les images de nos voyages
et de nos vies.
Nous ne partageons pas que des bouts du monde que nous avons vus
mais aussi des bouts de notre vécu au quotidien.
Si nous appliquons l’intentionnalité aux photos que nous prenons,
alors avec un peu de chance, nous les partageons intentionnellement.
Permettre aux gens de voir
des bouts de mon histoire et de mon point de vue en ligne
m'a rappelé que je n'étais pas seule.
Cela m'a aidée à établir du soutien et une communauté
pour en faire de même pour d'autres.
Que je sois claire :
je n'essaye pas de vous décourager de prendre des photos.
Même si des milliers de gens ont été à cet endroit précis
et ont pris exactement la même photo,
je vous encourage à sortir et à créer.
Le monde a besoin de chaque voix et point de vue,
y compris les vôtres.
Mais ce que j'essaye de vous montrer, c'est que le téléphone ou l'appareil
n'a pas besoin d'être constamment sorti.
J'essaye de vous encourager
à les ranger, juste un instant --
un instant rien que pour vous.
Revenons-en à Mesa Arch,
à la façon dont la pierre rougeoie
et les magnifiques couches de bleu en arrière-plan.
Et si la prochaine fois que vous étiez dans un lieu extraordinaire,
vous ne pouviez pas amener votre appareil, votre téléphone ?
Et si vous n'aviez pas le droit de prendre de photos ?
Vous sentiriez-vous limité ?
Ou vous sentiriez-vous soulagé ?
Que pouvons-nous faire ?
La prochaine fois que vous aurez envie de sortir votre appareil ou téléphone
ou, dans mon cas, quand vous réaliserez que vous l'avez déjà sorti --
(Rires)
Tout d'abord : arrêtez.
Marquez une pause.
Prenez une grande inspiration.
Regardez autour de vous : que remarquez-vous ?
Vivez-vous ce moment avec quelqu'un d'autre ?
Souvenez-vous que ce moment n'arrivera qu'une seule fois.
La photographie peut faire partie d'une belle expérience.
Ne la laissez pas être une barrière entre vous et la réalité.
Soyez intentionnel
et ne perdez pas un souvenir magnifique et irremplaçable
car vous étiez trop concentré à prendre une photo.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)